[Musique]
lundi 8 janvier bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur TV 78 voici les titres de
cette
édition après les températures 12 des
dernières semaines une vague de froid
s'est installée en France dès ce matin
les thermomètres étaient dans le négatif
et quelques flocons de neige sont même
tombés dans la journée ça devrait se
poursuivre pendant plusieurs jours dans
le département et la région où le plan
grand froid a été
déclenché il fallait donc bien se
couvrir hier pour le premier marathon de
l'année en France c'était organisé dans
les ivelines à cernlaville 1600
personnes ont participé à l'événement
qui proposait également un semi-marathon
une course de 10 km et un rassemblement
de
joëlettes clap de fin pour les
championnats de France de cyclisme sur
piste près de 140 athlètes se sont
disputés la vingtaine de titres en jeu
au Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin
au nivelin environ 5000 personnes sont
venu dans l'enceinte olympique de jeudi
à dimanche et puis le retour de l'invité
du 78 en 2è partie d'édition tout au
long du mois de janvier les maires de 50
ans en ieline viennent parler des grands
projets de l'année 2024 dans leur
commune ce soir c'est Jean-Baptiste
amonique qui inaugure l'exercice il est
le maire de villepreu et vous le voyez
autour de nous on n pas d'écran ce soir
les les télévisions autour de nous ne
fonctionnent pas à cause d'un problème
technique mais on a bien Michel Mido qui
est installé avec nous en plateau
bonsoir Michel moi je fonctionne he par
contre fnez vous allez nous éclairer
danser écler de la rédaction de TV 78
l'actualité on l'a vu dans les titres
est riche en terme de sport vous nous
parlerez des derniers résultats dans le
département on jou dans quel sport ce
weekend on jou notamment la coupe des
iines c'était les 8è de finale de la
Coupe des iines et vous verrez il y a eu
quelques surprises ça c'est du
football et ce sera donc tout à l'heure
vous nous présenterez également le reste
des actualités à retenir dans les
evelines ce sera dans quelques minutes
dans le
Gans écharpes et bonnet seront sans
doute nos alliés incournables pendant
les prochains jours est-ce que vous êtes
équipé Michel je pense que oui mais il
va faire froid quand même oui vous avez
vu une vague de froid touche cette
semaine la France et bien sûr les
ivelines les températures vont être
négatives et en dessous des minimales de
saison pendant plusieurs jours regardez
ce reportage d'Aurélie lafeille et de
vous michalel
Mido une chute de 10°gr pour ce début de
mois de janvier après un climat plutôt
doux pour les fêtes de fin d'année les
temps températures sont basses météoance
a annoncé une alerte neige et verglas
qui a pris fin à 13h la région
d'île-de-fance reste en vigilance jaune
grand froid au moins jusqu'à demain
mardi 8 janvier dans les ivelines ce
temps en dessous des normales
saisonnières n'a pas découragé les
coureurs du premier marathon de France
organisé par CERN la ville dimanche 7
janvier ça c'est très très bien passé
mieux que je pensais à part le vent en
fait qui qui ralentit beaucoup
évidemment
et un peu froid au départ mais sinon
super fait très froid j'ai des problèmes
cardios donc voilà je suis hyper
contente ça fait monter le cardio du
coup il faut ralentir un peu pour le WC
puis après il faut continuer quoi une
baisse de température surnommée Moscou
Paris provoqué par une masse d'air
glaciale provenant de Russie et d'Europe
du Nord ce phénomène se caractérise par
un temps sec et rude sur les ivelines
comme la France on a des l'air froid qui
est arrivé donc avec le retour des je
pour cette journée de lundi généralisé
il y a même pas de dégel dans la journée
donc les températures ne dépassent pas
0°gr en réalité même 1°gr on a du mal à
dépasser cette valeur et et on va se on
va rester donc sous ces nuages et avec
peut-être de petites chutes de neige
également la nuit prochaine avec des
températures qui sonont de l'ORD de - 2-
3°gr demain matin mercredi 10 janvier
sera le jour le plus frais de la semaine
le thermomètre descendra jusqu'à - 5°gr
pour tout le département il faudra
attendre vendredi pour sentir une légère
hausse du
mercure on fait le point sur le reste
des actualités dans les
Yvelines et Michel c'est lié au sujet du
grand froid le plan grand froid
justement et déclenchant en
Île-de-France comment ça va se traduire
dans les ivelines et bien grégoryi on a
appris en fin de journée l'activation du
plan grand froid dans les ivelines par
la préfecture par plan grand froid
comprenait un épisode de temps froid
caractérisé par sa persistance son
intensité et son étendue géographique
selon la définition de météoance on
écoute le préfet d'ivelines jean-jac
Brot au micro de Julien Leroi le préfet
de région î-de-france a déclenché pour
Paris le plan grand froid hier ce matin
il y avait coordination de tous les
départements le plan grand froid
consistera dès qu'il sera mis en œuvre
dans quelques minutes dans le
département des ivelines avoir une
préoccupation particulière pour les
personnes sans abri une augmentation de
plusieurs dizaines de places centaines
sans doute d'hébergement d'urgence
intensification des marodes et puis
réactivité en lien naturellement avec
les services hospitaliers les
municipalités qui sont au première loge
avec le Conseil départemental Dans ce et
les associations bien entendu dans ce
travail de mise à l'abri autre actualité
à retenir ce lundi le service des
urgences de l'hôpital de meland les
Mureau a engagé une grève illimitée en
tout cas quelquesuns des des agents sur
place oui c'est pas un communiqué de la
CGT qui a été annoncé une grève
illimitée à des urgences du centre
hospitalier intercommunal parmi les
revendications les équipes demandent la
création d'un poste d'infirmière
supplémentaire la nuit afin de sécuriser
les soins la direction aurait refuser se
justifiant d'un taux de passage annuel
qu'elle juge insuffisant selon le
communiqué de la CGT cette grève
illimitée s'inscrit dans un contexte
général de tension au sein des Urgences
toujours selon le syndicat de
l'établissement de nombreux agents ont
déjà fui le centre hospitalier en raison
de conditions de travail dégradé un
rassemblement a été organisé à 14h
aujourd'hui devant l'établissement une
information qui ne devrait pas
satisfaire les usagers de la ligne N oui
face aux nombreux dysfonctionnement que
subissent au quotidien les usagers entre
Paris- montparnas mont-elajolie Dreux et
rambouiller le directeur de la ligne
avait rencontré en décembre dernier cinq
maires du département au cours de cette
discussion les maires de plaisir
Villepreux ou encore les clés sous-bois
ont fait part de leur mécontentement et
de leur préoccupation face au à
désagrément que subissent leurs
habitants si le directeur de la ligne a
reconnu les difficultés dues à une
restitution des travaux tardifs et un
manque de personnel d'après les
informations recueillies par nos
confrères du Parisien aucun retour à la
normale n'est prévu pour les prochains
mois s'ajoute assez à dysfonctionnement
l'inquiétude de l'approche des Jos dans
le département une réunion trimestrielle
devrait tout de même être mise en place
entre les élus et la direction le
directeur de la ligne ài ça y est le
campus du PSG a accueilli tous ses
occupants les jeunes joueurs des centres
de formation et préformation du Paris
sa-germain ont fait leur entré au campus
de poissi ce dimanche ils ont été
accueillis par le président Nasser el
rifi au total ce sont 129 jeunes qui ont
découvert le centre d'entraînement avec
cette arrivée toutes les équipes du PSG
sont désormais réunies sur le site si
l'équipe professionnelle masculine était
déjà installée depuis juillet elle a été
rejointe par l'équipe féminine qui a
pris ses quartiers la semaine dernière
et justement ça poissi que l'équipe
Féminine disputera dorénavant ses matchs
oui et rendez-vous dès mercredi pour le
tout premier match dans cette nouvelle
infrastructure les Parisiennes recevront
le losk à 21h pour la 12e journée de D1
si vous souhaitez y assister des places
sont encore disponibles sur la
billetterie du Paris Saint-Germain match
bien sûr à domicile on termine avec ce
rendez-vous le lancement du CES
comprenait Consumer Electronic Show de
Las Vegas et des ivelinois vont
représenter le département oui le
Consumer Electronics Show pour ceux qui
ne se sont qui ne sont pas familiers
c'est le plus grand salon mondial de la
technologie il se tient aux États-Unis
du 9 au 12 janvier à 2024 et cette année
une association ivelinoise représentera
le département il s'agit de
l'association start ZUP située à
mantajolie depuis 2023 l'association
propose des formations au numérique au
public habitant dans les quartiers
prioritaires de son côté la région aussi
se mobilise Hotman nasrou vice-président
de la Région île-de-fance se rendra au
CES accompagné d'une délégation de 16
start-ups franilien manro également élu
de SaintQuentin en Eveline merci Michel
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi près
de chez vous vous êtes témoins d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
ielin n'hésitez pas à la partager sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78
[Musique]
news l'heure de la partie sport dans le
78 et on commence Mel par de la course à
pied le premier marathon et le premier
semi-marathon de France se sont déroulé
ce ce dimanche 7 janvier dans les ivines
plus de 1000 coureurs se sont donnés
rendez-vous dans la commune de CERN la
ville au cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse
un montage de ludovicque
luni c'est une tradition dans le monde
de la course depuis 10 ans chaque début
janvier des milliers de coureurs
investissent la petite commune de cerner
la ville juste après les fêtes de fin
d'année ce dimanche 7 janvier ces
sportifs venus de 61 départements et de
l'étranger viennent participer au
premier marathon et semi-marathon de
France au programme mais également un 10
km un meeting de joelette un vrai succès
pour ce rendez-vous qui se déroule au
cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse on s'est
dit si on veut avoir du monde il faut
que maintenant les les coureurs
cherchent un petit peu de sel dans leur
course à pied cherchent des défis et on
s'était dit ben si on fait ça au mois de
mai juin on aura pas grand monde par
contre si on fait ça tout de suite après
les fêtes on peut avoir du monde on a
commencé avec 200 coureurs en 2014 et là
pour les 10 ans on a refusé du monde et
on a bloqué à 1600 personnes dans le
froid et sous la grisaille le
semi-marathon a été remporté chez les
hommes par Gaspar fondbonne en 1h 13
minutes et 31 secondes chez les
féminines Carole Stéphan 4e en 2023
remporte cette fois-ci l'épreuve 2024 ça
s'est très très bien passé mieux que je
pensais à part le vent en fait qui qui
ralentit beaucoup évidemment et un peu
le froid au départ mais sinon super du
côté du marathon plus de 400 courageux
ont pris le départ de l'épreuve cette
année chez les féminine garant sperro
s'impose en 3h et 4 minutes et 36
secondes chez les hommes la course a été
remportée par le villeprosien Nicolas
duil en 2h 41 minutes et 5 secondes les
Vinois s'impos pour la deuxème fois
consécutive sur l'épreuve bah on m'avait
on m'avait donné le dos 1 donc j'avais
un peu la pression parce que j'ai gagné
l'année dernière mais c'est jamais gagné
d'avance tir en marathon parce que c'est
c'est quand même long donc on sait pas
comment V réagir les jambes mais ça
s'est bien passé donc je suis content
une 11e édition est déjà programmée pour
l'année prochaine elle sera organisée
cette fois-ci le 5 janvier
2025 bravo eux ils sont bien courageux
je parce qu'on l'a dit il faisait très
froid ce weekend ça continue cette
semaine dans le département on parle à
présent dans le reste des actualités de
football ont joué ce weekend les 8e de
finale de la Coupe des ivelines
hardardricour s'impose 4 à 2 face à
Valée 78 et l'encours s'impose au tir au
but contre rambouillé voisin gagne 31
contre garganville poissi s'impose 1 à0
sur le terrain de feroll match
spectaculaire entre maison la fite et
maison la fite et Chantelou lvin je vais
y arriver 5 à 4 les Murau gagnent 3-1
contre le chaînet même score pour virofl
contre Sartrouville enfin Montesson perd
3-0 contre joui en Josas les quarts de
finale se disputeront le 25 février
prochain parler à présent de basket dans
le championnat de National 3 ont joué ce
samedi trappe s'impose à domicile contre
foyer jeune champul sur le score de 105
à 89 de son côté l'entente le chînet
Versailles a perdu 84 à 70 sur le
terrain de céser l Villain au classement
trappe et 9e du championnat et le LCV 78
est dernier de cette division après 13
matchs disputés d'ailleurs tjours jou à
basket une projection d'un film a eu
lieu à châau elle a retenu votre
attention vous connaissez la voix du
basket français George Eddie cette
yelinois l'accent américain était
présent ce vendredi au cinéma Louis jouv
de Chatou il a présenté à cette occasion
le film do it in the park en présence du
coréalisateur Kevin couliot un
documentaire sur le basket et les
playgrounds de New York le maire de la
commune erriic duoulin était également
présent pour l'événement georgey est
habitué des playgr il joue depuis de
nombreuses années à Chatou enfin un mot
du Dakar ex Paris la compétition a
commencé ce vendredi on en a parlé la
semaine dernière il a 77 ans il est pour
la 32e fois au départ du rally dakard
originaire de Chatou Jean-Pierre strugot
est le doyen de la course il participe à
cette course mythique avec la team MD
rally sport au volant d'un buggy au
classement général Jean-Pierre strugot
et pour l'instant à la 170e place avec
le pilote Christophe Crespo à l'issue de
la 2uxè étape son objectif est de
terminer dans les 30 premiers à la fin
on 77 ans pour Jean-Pierre strugot et on
va parler de cyclisme à présent cyclisme
sur piste cyclisme sur piste les
championnats de France étaient
programmés pendant 4 jours au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en ilvine du jeudi à
4 janvier au dimanche 7 janvier plus de
140 sportifs venus de toute la France
sont affrontés dont des membres de
l'équipe de France reportage le
vélodrome national a vibré pendant 4
jours au rythme des championnats de
France 4 jours aux 140 sportifs venus
des quatre coins de la France se sont
affrontés sur la future piste olympique
de 50 ans en Evelin selon la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme le bilan est
positif le centre PIST a bien vécu on a
eu des des belles retransmissions télé
jusqu'au podium protocolaire très
apprécié on a pu entendre des
marseillaises à capella avec des
spectateurs qui ont poussé la voix et je
crois que côté organisation côté public
billetterie avec le soutien de de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin et du
département des ivelines on a réussi à
un beau championnat de France pour
débuter l'année 2024 au total plus de
5000 spectateurs sont venus sur les 4
jours de compétition pour assister à cet
événement organisé pour la deuxème fois
dans la structure après 2019 un
championnat de France avec un très très
haut niveau on a vu des courses
exceptionnelles que ce soit au niveau
masculin au niveau féminin il est très
intéressant il y a plein de
rebondissements c'est assez sympa à
suivre je un habitué des championnat de
France c'est un très beau championnat de
France et à domicile c'est encore mieux
parmi ceux qui ont fait vibrer le public
on retrouve Tom de rash le PIST star de
l'équipe de France à remporté deux
titres de champion de France sur le
Kerin et le kilomètre une bonne
répétition pour les athlètes tricolores
en vue des prochains mois
voir si si on a progressé cet hiver on a
bien travailler et je pense qu' qu'il y
a de belles choses qui qui sont
ressorties et voilà de se confronter
aussi on fait on fait ce disport de
niveau pour se confronter à au meilleur
donc là il y a eu des belles batailles
avec avec les collègues je pense aussi
au match avec Aryan en vitesse en caring
où où ça a bien matché c'était vraiment
une bonne semaine sur ce pointlà les
championnats de France pourraient
revenir dans les prochaines années à 50
ans
Eveline le Vélodrome national de 50 ans
living qui sera le théâtre sportif du
cyclisme sur piste pendant les Joos de
2024 je vous rappelle grégoryie qu'on
est à moins de 200 jours des Jeux
Olympiques 2024 dans les ivines on va
accueillir le BMX Race le VTT le
cyclisme sur piste donc le golf le
cyclisme sur route le marathon
l'équitation et le pentatelot moderne r
ça h moi en tout cas j'ai hâte j'imagine
que vous aussi ou merci Michel pour
toutes ces informations sportives on se
retrouve bien sûr lundi prochain lundi
prochain pour d'autres actualités
sportives avant de passer à l'invité du
78 dernier coup d'œil un petit coup
d'œil pardon aux prévisions météo de
demain et comme nous vous le disions en
début d'édition le froid est là va et va
s'intensifier dans les prochains jours
demain matin il fera - 3°gr sur une
grande partie du territoire c'est à
Oudan que l'on aura la valeur la plus
haute avec -1°gr Oudan où des éclaircis
sont même prévus dans l'après-midi le
ciel sera nuageux ailleurs dans les
evvelines le thermomètre montera au
maximum à 0°gr pensez donc à bien vous
couvrir la journée la plus froide et
prévu pour mercredi et ce mardi 9
janvier nous fêterons les Alix tout de
suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et c'est Jean-Baptiste amoni qui est
avec nous bonsoir bonsoir bonne année
merci à vous également maire de
Villepreux et vice-président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans yeline délégé
aux transport et aux mobilités durbles
on va parler avec vous des grands
projets de l'année 2024 dans votre
commune ici même sur ce plateau tout au
long du mois de janvier l'ensemble des
maires de Saint-Quentin en yeline
justement vont se succéder pour se
prêter à l'exercice déjà une première
question qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
l'année 2023 très rapidement à villepreu
oh plusieurs images me viennent à
l'esprit euh d'abord évidemment toutes
les difficultés qu'on a pu rencontrer
euh nous élus locaux euh et avec aussi
nos nos concitoyens je pense euh
évidemment aux questions de pouvoir
d'achat à la crise énergétique euh et
puis surtout les grands conflits les
grands bouleversements du monde avec le
conflit en Israël et et en Palestine
toujours cette guerre qui sévit aux
portes de l'Europe avec avec l'Ukraine
et la Russie mais quelques notes
d'optimisme aussi et puis de belles
images comme vous avez pu les montrer
avec les Goos qui vont bientôt arriver
justement c'est avec de l'optimisme que
vous vous abordez cette année 2024 quel
est votre état d'esprit aujourd'hui
lucide et optimiste c'est-à-dire la
lucidité sur
ces difficultés de l'année 2023 mais qui
sont encore là et que nous devrons
affronter
ble en 2024 mais aussi de l'optimisme
parce que je crois qu'on en a besoin et
puis il y a quand même un certain nombre
de raisons de l'être donc oui en tout
cas moi je sais que au moment des vœux
que j'aurai l'occasion de présenter au
villeprosiens le 13 janvier prochain ce
sera ce ce discours là que je tiendrai
soyons lucide sur les difficultés qui
sont encore devant nous mais abordonsles
avec beaucoup d'optimisme vous parlez de
difficultés ce qu'on pourrait voir par
exemple une des impôts locaux augmentés
à villepre en 2024 est-ce que c'est un
levier que vous vous vous réservez de
d'activer dans dans les prochains mois
alors nous ne l'avons pas fait depuis le
début du mandat depuis notre prise de
fonction et notre arrive aux
responsabilité en en 2020 on a
privilégié évidemment des optimisations
on a réduit autant que possible les
dépenses de fonctionnement dans un
contexte où on avait une augmentation
des dépenses de fonctionnement que je
qualifierais de de subi avec la hausse
des tarifs de l'énergie CIT 1 million
d'euros quand même pour la commune de
Villepreux avec le gaz et l'électricité
mais on a tenu bon et puis on n pas
augmenté la fiscalité locale en
l'occurrence la taxe foncière he parce
que c'est le seul impôt qui reste je
rappelle que c'est un impôt évidemment
qui impacte les propriétaires he
seulement de de de la commune on a
résisté c'est pas au projet c'est pas au
programme de les augmenter en 2024 mais
néanmoins on va essayer de trouver de
nouvelles marges de manœuvre toujours
pour investir pour la commune avec des
projets vous l'avez parlé hein vous en
avez parlé l'année 2024 c'est une année
olympique à Villepreux le sport sera
justement une grande cause communale
cette année pourquoi ce choix et comment
ça va se traduire très concrètement le
sport c'est plusieurs choses alors
forcément l'année olympique euh je pense
que on n'invente pas le fil à couper le
beur en fonant de du sport la grande
cause communale en en 2024 c'est une
évidence euh mais tout en étant une
évidence je pense que c'est important de
mettre le sport au centre du débat sur
cette année on va avoir euh euh une
approche aussi de santé publique euh
avec cette grande cause communale le
président de la République l'a encore
dit ce matin et c'est d'ailleurs la
grande cause aussi euh euhtionale
nationale donc il y a une certaine
résonance évidemment qui qui se fait euh
l'idée c'est de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
séquence qui est celle des JO pour faire
de cette année une année riche en
événement en action dans nos école pour
évidemment les enfants on va prévoir des
challenges sportifs des Olympiades on va
organiser une dictée géante qui sera
narré par un sportif ou une sportive de
de de renommée et puis pour tous les
publics je pense aussi à nos seniors on
a la chance d'avoir et bien dans notre
résidence de l'UR mala blonde pour
personne en situ situation pour les
personnes autonomes plusieurs véloos
électriques aussi donc il y a une notion
on va dire de d'activité physique qui
est évidemment bonne pour le corps et
bonne pour l'esprit et puis aussi pour
fédérer les villespreusiennes et les
villeespreusiens et vivre ensemble comme
vous l'avez dit des moments importants
des moments de partage et de communion
c'est quand même pas tout toutes les
années et toutes les décennies loin de
là qu'on a la chance d'accueillir les
GEOS donc il faut aussi que ces Jeux
Olympiques sur 50 ans en Eveline
puissent être vécu par les popul les
populations de toutes les communes de
l'agglomération alors à côté ca il y
aura d'autres grands projets à
Villepreux pour l'année 2024 avant la
fin du premier trimestre d'ailleurs il y
aura l'inauguration de la Maison des
Arts qui va voir le jour à l'emplacement
de l'ancienne école élémentaire Jacques
gilet fermée en 2021 c'est un lieu
culturel qui va accueillir les
associations artistiques de Villepreux
plusieurs années de travaux ont été
nécessaires oui c'est un projet qu'on a
lancé dès le début du mandat on est
parti d'un constat c'est que la
fermeture de l'école JAC gillc qui est
donc comme vous l'avez rappelé situé
dans le dans le vieux village de la
commune euh on ne pouvait pas fermer les
portes de cet établissement et ne rien
proposer derrière c'est un peu le
dernier morceau de vie du village qui a
vu au fil des décennies malheureusement
un certain nombre de de commerces
disparaître et donc ce très beau
bâtiment en brick qui était d'ailleurs
avant d'être une école une ancienne
imprimerie du siè du siècle dernier on a
décidé de le réhabiliter euh et de le
réinvestir et donc ce sera une une
maison des arts qui va accueillir
l'école de musique qui va accueillir des
associations culturel finalement un pôle
associatif et culturel pour les acteurs
de la commune et je crois que là ça
montre bien aussi la logique
d'optimisation aussi foncière qui est la
nôtre c'est-à-dire que plutôt que de
partir tout de suite sur une
construction nouvelle d'avoir des
investissements qui sont peut-être
parfois un peu plus onéreux un peu plus
coûteux on part d'un bâtiment existant
on essaie de lui trouver évidemment un
projet qui fasse sens et qui serve
l'intérêt local et puis on se met tous
en ordre de bataille pour pouvoir
proposer quelque chose donc on va être
très heureux d'inaugurer ce bâtiment euh
et d'ailleurs qui est conçu par
l'architecte de la médiathèque de du
Nautilus de villepre qui est aujourd'hui
sous pavillon saint-cantinois qui est un
véritable bijou architectural donc oui
une belle inauguration à venir et
l'aboutissement d'un d'un projet de
longue date un peu plus de 3 millions
d'euros et euh largement financé par nos
partenaires et notamment la région
î-de-france que je remercie alors l'une
des priorités de votre mandat c'est
l'école vous avez amorcé l'année
dernière un plan de rénovation
énergétique pour trois écoles de la
commune euh le montant c'est 2,8
millions d'euros sont concernit le
groupe scolaire rosancury l'école
maternelle du prieuré et la maternelle
du valjoyeux et où est-ce qu'on en est
concrètement aujourd'hui dans ce plan il
faut rappeler qu'à Villepreux on a la
chance de pouvoir faire tout son
parcours éducatif sur la commune
c'est-à-dire que de la maternelle même
en passant par la crèche jusqu'au lycée
nous avons tous les établissements
scolaires sur la ville de villepr c'est
une richesse c'est ce qui rend aussi
notre commune attractive et très
familiale mais nous avons fait un
constat c'est qu'aujourd'hui 37 % des
bâtiments publics aujourd'hui de la
commune sont des bâtiments dédiés au
Scola au périscola et ils représentent à
eux seuls 50 % de nos dépenses d'énergie
et donc on parlait encore là il y a à
l'instant des dépenses de fonctionnement
qui augmentent notamment en raison des
coûts de l'énergie il y a un double
objectif pour nous d'abord améliorer
évidemment le confort de toutes celles
et ceux qui sont dans ces bâtiments à
commencer par les enfants mais sans
oublier le personnel de la mairie je
pense aux adsem je pense au personnel de
la restauration municipale aux
animateurs aux enseignants euh et puis
surtout euh et bien être dans une
logique évidemment à après la sobriété
subie de sobriété choisie c'est-à-dire
de continuer à investir pour améliorer
le confort de tous et surtout réduire
notre impact énergétique et et nos
dépenses énergétiques et donc on a fait
quelques travaux en 2023 notamment à à
l'été pour être prêt pour la rentrée
scolaire de de septembre et vous l'avez
dit les travaux vont se poursuivre on va
continuer sur jean- Rostan et et Marie
cur et puis les autres écoles feront
l'objet de travaux fin 2024 début 2025
en tout cas c'est un grand plan
d'investissement qui est porté par par
la commune et on a réussi là aussi à
aller chercher des fonds des aides là où
elles étaient disponible je pense
notamment au fond vert auprès de l'État
mais c'est un projet ambitieux qui
demande évidemment beaucoup d'engagement
de de la part de la ville des agents et
et de l'ensemble de nos partenaires mais
qui est évidemment primordial à l'heure
où on parle de transition énergétique
alors plus rapidement pour terminer
parce qu'il nous reste deux sujets à
aborder la thématique des énergies
renouvelables vous avez d'ailleurs été
missionné l'année dernière par le
gouvernement pour travailler sur la
future loi de programmation
énergieclimat mais qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire sur cette thématique à
villepreuf alors c'est très simple
aujourd'hui vous allez avoir une loi qui
va normalement être présentée au au
Parlement qui et bien impose de réduire
notre consommation d'énergie fossile et
de porter évidemment les énergies
renouvelables à un plus fort taux euh il
va falloir électrifier et il va falloir
se tourner vers les autres modes
d'énergie renouvelable et c'est ce que
nous voulons faire à Villepreux nous
sommes en relation là aussi avec un
certain nombre de porteurs de projets
des acteurs privés d'autres
collectivités
on se penche notamment sur la question
de la géothermie et puis vous savez avec
la loi d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables l'état nous a demandé à
toutes les communes d'identifier des
zones
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables sur le territoire on a
d'ailleurs délibéré en décembre sur le
sujet il y a une concertation publique
qui va avoir lieu tout au long du mois
de janvier à Villepreux et donc on
espère bien que les habitants s'emparent
de cette thématique puisque les énergies
renouvelable c'est aussi le quotidien
des villes priens et la dernière
thématique que je voulais aborder avec
vous c'est la sécurité plus précisément
la vidéo protection Villepreux compte
une trentaine de de caméras de
surveillance cette année vous allez
lancer un audit pour un nouvel
investissement sur la vidéo prototection
bah pourquoi cette réflexion et ça
pourrait déboucher sur sur quoi
concrètement des des caméras
supplémentaires oui en l'occurrence et
puis moderniser le système de vidéo
protection on a un peu plus de 37
caméras aujourd'hui sur la commune de
Villepreux on a fait d'abord sur le
début du mandat deux choses sur la
partie sécurité on a augmenté les
effectifs de la police municipale ce qui
nous permet de passer à deux patrouilles
et d'élargir les plages horaires on a a
acquéri un nouveau véhicule pour notre
police municipale pour faire encore une
fois deux patrouilles maintenant il faut
qu'on avance sur la vidéo protection
donc la vidéo protection pour ne pas
partir tous àzimut il faut d'abord qu'on
ait un audit qui va poser un constat
très précis sur l'état actuel du parc et
voir comment on peut le moderniser je
pense notamment aux entrées de ville je
crois que c'est important qu'on puisse
couvrir nos entrées de ville et puis
regarder là où on a maintenant des
nouveaux équipements et notamment aussi
dans le nouveau quartier des haau du
moulin qui aujourd'hui n'est pas couvert
en vidéo protection comment on peut
proposer et bien une une nouvelle un
nouveau dispositif qui corresponde
davantage maintenant à la réalité de la
commune alors pour terminer
Jean-Baptiste amonique il nous reste
moins d'une minute on demandera cet
exercice à tous les mes on vous propose
une carte blanche pour terminer un sujet
que vous souhaitez aborder vous avez
moins d'une minute allez-y un sujet
allez allons-y sur la thématique de
l'engagement parce que ça fera ça
bouclera la boucle avec la grande cause
communale qui était celle de Villepreux
l'année dernière je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on le voit que ce soit dans le pays dans
nos villes on on a cruellement besoin
d'engagement que ce soit l'engagement
dans les équipes municipales ça on le
voit tous les jours mais aussi dans la
vie associative donc ma carte blanche ce
serait de dire abordons cette année
comme je le disais en introduction avec
optimisme il y a tout un tas de projets
à porter il y a différentes formes
d'engagement possible et donc je
voudrais encourager surtout les jeunes
générations à ne pas avoir peur des
responsabilités et à ne pas craindre le
temps que cela pourrait prendre mais en
tout cas à s'engager quel que soit allez
le le le sujet sur lesquel il souhaitent
évidemment se mobiliser il faut se
lancer en en a on en a vraiment besoin
dans notre société c'est ce qui fait
vivre aussi la solidarité et l'esprit de
cohésion nationale merci d'avoir été
avec nous jean-baptisteique maire de
villepr et encore une nouvelle fois
bonne
année pour cette année 2024 merci à vous
c'est la fin du 78 merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve dès demain pour
une nouvelle édition belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78